the girag an experience so what what is
it like working with the Vice guys we
fucking love you know I love vice man
vice they're my best you I've worked
with so many people and vice just lets
you do your thing yeah and and that's
the best part and like I just went
through a whole week I was at Ted I'm a
TED fellow this year and I went through
a whole week of people telling me what
to do where to be and it was like being
at a fucking Scientology summer camp was
horrible yeah tell me what the fuck
happened they told you that you you you
can't leave yeah like before you go to
like you need to participate in Ted you
need to be them all right cool like I'm
like minds are reasonable if you have to
do something in LA you can go do
something in LA right I gave them like
four or five days in my time like I was
there every single 13 hours like every
day they have 13 hours of fucking
activities they have mapped out for you
some days like 15 16 hours right if you
go to their after events and I like
that's way too much fucking human in
Iraq days yeah explain this so you go
there and you're gonna go and do your
own TED speech right yeah so you do your
own TED speech what is the other stuff
they have for you they want you to be
available for like networking cocktail
events like attendees want to talk to
you you need to be available and I was
like look i-i've done a lot like I put
people on like I put them in touch with
ad agency people I put them in touch
with other people to do business with
other artists I was introducing everyone
and I thought I was good so I went
yesterday to go do DVD awesome I went a
met up show I met up awesome and I went
and now they called me today on the way
over here and they were like we're
taking your ted fellowship where so why
are you taking the ted fellowship like
because you went to LA I was like you're
in Long Beach I just went to LA for the
afternoon to do the fucking podcast
you're fucking crazy and they're like
you took this spot from somebody who
would have gone to every talk and been
in everything I was like yo the other
people weren't there for everything but
you're also just crazy like yeah fucking
crazy you're crazy
then I paying you know they don't pay
that since that's you go they do it for
the love and they want you for seven
days 12 to 15 hours a day
what and you can't just leave to go do
something some work that you have to do
yes fucked up yeah what what is it where
people fuck up everything yeah
even something is amazing is
because Ted I remember the first TED
talk that I ever saw on the internet a
couple years ago we have a whole Ted
thread on my message board about great
great TED episodes yeah like the one how
to be happy is great oh there's so many
of them uh Graham Hancock just gave one
in the war on consciousness about
ayahuasca and his own problems with
kicking cannabis he had like a crazy
weed habit where he's high all day every
day for like decades and then he like it
was it was a crutch for him was like a
real problem um great TED talk about it
though there's so much good stuff but
then you hear shit like this you know
like even they suck
yeah like even someone finds a way to
fuck up even something as amazing as Ted
yeah the speakers are great I quit I
can't say a damn bad thing every single
one of the fellows is like inspirational
amazing doing great work the thing is
though something gets so good and people
feel the power that they have and then
they impose rules and that's how society
got created in the beginning
somebody got so liked and got so much
power that they could force you to do
things that were entirely unnatural and
inhuman that's so ridiculous to think
that a guy like you is as busy as you
could give up that much time yeah and be
angry if you vary from their schedule at
all that that sounds like there's more
to it
Ted's a racist yet culturally kind of
crazy too cuz other people missed and
they kind of picked on me for it but
even before I got out I was like oh my
birthday is Friday you want me to stay
till Saturday can I at least have my
girl stay with me like and I'll just use
them Vic oh we can't because you have a
roommate at Ted so you're like 30 40
year old people staying at roommate I
was like wait a minute wait a minute
wait they make you room with people wait
a minute why how can they do that
I only tell you who to sleep with yeah
they were yes and they were like you
have two room it's part of the Ted
experience and I was like this is a cold
at this point you have crossed the
thrusts you are now fucking Scientology
yes wait that's create shit
so they assign you they say you know
what we think that Eddie would grow if
he lived with Sascha for a week yeah so
some crazy fuck who's the Sascha Shulgin
who's in there cooking up crystal meth
and whatever the fuck he's doing he
would have to stay with that guy yes I
mean luckily
with this dude soft what who was amazing
cool cat okay yes yeah you were really
thick to be able to pull the name of the
dude out is amazing his name was soft
wet and I stay with him but I was like
I'm 30 I've been stayed in a hotel with
people in a minute you know how big is
the hotel it's a small shitty hotel it's
the Hyatt Regency looks like a fucking
Airport Hotel him so you bought you're
like in the bed next to this guy yeah so
you had to hear each other snore yeah oh
dude oh fuck Danny what the fuck is that
and they also hold this shit at Long
Beach and it's like next to like across
the street literally you have
back-to-back Outback PF Changs
and like Subway it's ridiculous but the
whole thing is just weird I was like
I'll pay for my own room though no
you're not allowed I was like you're not
allowed to pay for your own room yeah
they're crazy they just want to control
you that is amazing so I still love the
talks I love all the speakers but the
organisation is fucked
that's hilarious that they think that
they could have that kind of influence
over you it's part of the Ted experience
Eddie is part of the Ted experience
owned only that no one's talked about
this before because this seems like
straight-up Boy Scouts yeah you know
what is the thing is most people they
need Ted they need Ted to put you on
they want the cosign and most people
it's like if you do something for me I
won't say anything about you but that's
I mean I think Joe you're the same way I
don't give a fuck what you do for me if
you're a fucking weirdo and you're about
to start some new cult conference
religion I'm gonna say something I'm not
all your rules I would write a book
about this yeah if I try if they
actually try to get me to do what they
wanted me to do for four five six seven
days whatever it was and not paying you
they send packets to to be like this is
how to network with billionaires Wow
like how to go to network with
billionaire's how to go to a network and
talk to people and like talk to
potential people who could collaborate
and work with you they're like don't
just go ask them for money and I'm like
this is crazy oh my god I mean so just
go ask them for money and it's in the
packets yeah and you're a grown-ass man
and they pick you like you're obviously
intelligent if you getting picked for
ten and they're like today when it rains
you should pack a punch it's wild see
that what that is
pardon okay what that is is exactly the
opposite of the vehicle that got them
there the vehicle that
them there is the Internet what got them
there is the fact that the freedom of
the Internet allows people to exchange
interesting conversations like that hey
you got a listen to this got a washes
it's lady gave the speech on monkeys it
was amazing whatever you and what they
did is the exact opposite yeah and
that's why even though Obama is focusing
on gun control the most important debate
that Americans will face in the next
five years is Internet freedom internet
freedom is the most important debate we
will face and we have so fucking blind
to it because the lobbyists are doing it
under like under our noses yeah you
surely should have the right and ability
to put your own website up and control
your own content and express yourself
any in any way shape form you choose and
the benefits of that have been
staggering to our culture over the last
couple of years yeah just just over the
last ten yeah you know and the idea that
corporations might have the ability to
step in and stop that or regulate that
or restrict that or censor you if in
anything that you do and somehow or
another if anything you do and somehow
or another one way or forms cost them
money
yeah and they decide that this is
something that has to be stopped they're
going to be able to do that and yes we
do something and once somebody realizes
they have their hand on the faucet and
they have the ability to turn it on and
turn it off people get crazy you've seen
that study it's like Ted like these yet
people yeah they even want power yeah
they do this shit where they invite
these people to go talk and they
actually don't put up everybody's talks
until this year they used to pick and
choose and cherry-pick the talks they
put up and you would go there for a week
15 hours a day do all their shit and
then imagine if they didn't put up your
talk what if you talk sucks if your talk
sucked I feel like it should just go
suck on the internet like I don't go mad
at each other on the internet you know
right but maybe if yes and no because if
you like say if you have a comedy
conference and you had all these
comedians do sets but some of them were
just dog shit did you want that set to
represent your your company know you
would you know you wouldn't do it yeah I
wouldn't I you know if I did though
invite someone and they stayed for a
week and I didn't pay them I would be
like the least I owe you is the
opportunity to quite pass
there's three people on the planet earth
that enjoy your vegan I mean yeah that's
one point yeah that's a point I guess
but I know what you're saying to protect
the brand it makes a little sense but
you know for the most part most people's
talks are fucking good yeah they're
there for a reason
Yeah right really different they're not
gonna get an open mic or the TED talk er
yeah but they gotta bring your show
right but they give opportunities to a
lot of weird people I mean it is
absolutely possible there must be I bet
if we just ask I bet we're ignorant to
it but we just say show me the TED Talks
that suck a fat dick yeah they're gonna
say okay Twitter Twitter people please
show me the TED Talks that suck a fat
dick yeah I mean if anyone wants to see
the Sarah Silverman TED talk there was
never let out she get a sec she gave us
never let out no they never let it out
cuz she made fun of Ted see I would have
fuckin wanted to watch that immediate
really and the thing is if you're
confident is that you're loud you you
can laugh at yourself they don't know
how to laugh at themselves she made fun
of Ted in what way
like during her talk it's like the
mythology of it I didn't see the talk
obviously but there was a Sarah
Silverman TED talk they'd never let out
Wow Wow we need to get serious hey yeah
I need to run into her somewhere I could
I can make it happen okay am I gonna
happen hurt um I I've never heard
anything bad about Ted before so that's
why this is such a shock it is weird
though you meet the donors and stuff and
they can't tell Asian people apart they
can't tell African people apart and it's
just it's weird man like they're nice
and everybody means well did they call
you David Choe ha ha no they they just
mistake you for other fellows cuz so
many of them are Asian really that's
funny yeah how many different people do
it every year uh every year they pick
like 20 fellows and then they pick a
bunch of other people for the main stage
so yeah I mean no it is it is a ill
Organization I still even though they
booted me today I loved the speakers I
loved the talks and I wanted to continue
but I hope that they at least you know
they could say I suck and that's fine
they could be like Eddie's a shithead he
went to LA he did the fucking podcast
and he sucks but I hope they just
changed rules for future people so
listen you didn't do anything wrong
they're crazy and all they represent is
a distribution method for the greatest
minds on earth that's all they represent
it's not that they are the greatest
minds on earth it's just there's so many
interesting people today we live in
amazing time and just when you good
something like Ted whatever the Ted
stands for it became synonymous on the
internet with fascinating talks yeah
boom and then it's off yeah but you
wanted to you could do the Eddie Wong's
you know fascinating motherfuckers on
Vice and do the exact same thing yes
like I think there's a lot of room for
that cuz conferences like I would love
to hear more people from you know
downtown LA downtown New York walking
and doing these ideas because they don't
find those dudes they find academics
they find people playing ancient
instruments they find people that are
you know working nature things and and
they have their kind of like cultural
sect you know but there is a lot of room
to find genius in other place geniuses
everywhere you know this yeah you travel
around the world you find genius
anywhere so there's room for conferences
that like look under different cultures
cuz they're kind of looking under the
same stones all the time right and
they're gonna run out of bugs yeah and
I'm one of the I'm one of the first time
they've stepped out to be like alright
there's this dude he's Chinese he's in
the hip hop he lives in downtown New
York he used to sell drugs he now has a
restaurant I think I was the only
working chef that was a tenth fellow so
I I was one of their choices that was
really out there but it just didn't work
out
didn't work out cuz you're not willing
to be a fucking slave and sleep in a
hotel room with a stranger for a week
yeah that's insane honey I rehearsed for
two days I fucking did the tour I did
everything I'm supposed to do and then I
was like I'm a just peace out for like a
half day in debug Wow you know you need
that since that's crazy and in fact they
don't pay you it's crazy you guys need
to do a vice show exposing Ted how
Looney ten apps I told vice that I would
if I said before I got booted I sent
them in email like yo you gotta see this
shit it's like the beginnings of
Scientology Wow
it is so true that once people have a
position of power and influence and
people want to be a part of them Pio go
corrupt yo and micros the fresh hole
what is the threshold at which something
becomes a religion yeah it's kind of
insane it's so easy to start a cult
today yeah there's so many people
looking to jump on board you know all
the people that would have a hundred
years ago become Catholics now they're
like man Pope just won't stop fucking
kids I can't do this I need a new cult I
don't know why people still believe in
these
like you look at what these people are
doing like what these what's happening
in the Catholic Church is insane fucking
Pope's resigning yeah this is the first
time it's gotten so hot that the Pope's
like I'm out of here
he's asked for immunity from the
Catholic from the Italian government
from prosecution because he's
responsible for shielding pedophiles he
personally and a lot of people don't
know this the Pope personally
responsible for taking pedophiles and
shifting them away to another place
where they molested more kids and what
would you expect you don't these people
aren't allowed to have sex
yeah it's natural to want to have sex
it's natural to want to go to LA and do
podcasts you know soon that you cannot
come to Ted and have sex without condoms
I'd be like fuck that did you measure
yours and no unprotected size there's no
raw doggin at Ted legal law no ass
fucking while you're here oh man now
while you're at Ted fellow there would
be mutiny I wonder if they would have
liked you you could slowly start
imposing behavior standards you know on
fellows you know if you want to call it
like a TED fellow or whatever new
organization you want to start they do
shit like you should have a standing you
should give a standing ovation when this
person calls you should do this and that
it's not easy yeah that's what wait a
minute wait a minute fake standing
ovations yeah and they were also saying
like you know when the founder comes
Chris Anderson comes like you don't have
to give him a standing ovation like you
know it's nice if you want to but he
doesn't actually need you to do it I'm
like the fact that you needed to give me
this fake halfway disclaimer is so
fucking strange wow that's so strange
ah yeah tell you who to and not to give
standing ovations to who's a lot to
apply you have to apply to go to Ted to
attend and then once you're accepted you
pay $8,000 hahaha that's a mind fuck
wait a minute
yeah you had to pay no hell no ID but
the people who do it they apply like oh
okay so that people that attend the
strict audience members yeah oh you got
to want to be so down so bad to do that
to go through an application process and
then fucking pay that's a lot of money
how many people are going now maybe
it'll go I don't I think uh like 2003
them whoa holy shit yeah that's a lot of
money they make holy shit yeah that's a
lot of money yeah they make offer you
yeah two thousand people paying eight
thousand dollars is how much
six 360,000 no sixteen hundred what is
it
160,000 know that what anymore no it's
way more than that
it's like sixteen million I think but
yeah
mm mm we're so Cyrus yeah 16 million mm
time Jamie you don't know shit about
your numbers yeah and I didn't even
bother calculation shows masca asian
always I'm asking Asians from now on
pretty sure 16 million if Jamie you
silly bitch what is a brunt do you ever
go to calculate a bill tonight remember
what's number it's got two thousand
times eight eight thousand gotta be 16
million what's two thousand times eight
thousand this might answer your question
it is 1.6 million I think Oh 1.6 million
okay I was one off yes I did
okay that makes a lot of bread so they
made 1.6 million
no no it's 16 million yeah 16 mil yeah
all right the human calculator was fast
very nice so um they made sixteen
million which is even crazier and they
did this in this time where you were
there and no one got AAA paid nobody got
paid Wow yup we are suckers dude are
suckers and there was telling you like
you're gonna get exposure I was like no
lie more people listen to the Joe Rogan
experience that's true Ted suck it yeah
Ted we got you beat by like a million yo
but that's still nuts man that's a lot
of money we're not making that money we
need to make that money you guys shared
thousand people Joe Rogan about ten
million dollars each I know how to do it
I'm gonna just raise the bar and only
get really stupid rich people
you